a month ago she was campaigning to be
Labour's deputy leader today she'll
dress up in full personal protective
gear to treat coronavirus patients in a
and E Labor's dr. Rosanna alençon has
answered the call of the NHS and
returned to work at her local hospital
in South London she's joining us now
hello to you thank you for joining us my
goodness me quite change for you over
the last month's how are you adapting to
it yes well at the end of the day is not
a real privilege to go back to work
obviously I never stopped doing shift I
became an MP but I've really ramped up
the shifts but I'm doing now and I'm
back in there on the front line and as
far as I'm concerned saving lives is the
only thing that matters so yes it is a
far cry from the campaign to become
Beiber's deputy leader but really for me
this is absolutely the most important
thing so it's a pleasure
yeah politician to front line but also
daughter we heard you speaking in the
House of Commons about your dad this is
what you had to say my NHS colleagues on
the front line are already stressed with
the pressure that they faced last night
I visited my father in a care home and
I'm acutely aware that I may have fed
him for the very last time we are in
unprecedented times I would like to know
where was the forward planning for PPE
for our NHS and care staff how is he
doing he's okay he's not eating much
because he only really eats if my
Branagh or I go and feeds him and
obviously we have really been observing
the social distancing measures and not
going to visit him there has been talk
of us seeing him from the roadside of
bringing to the window near the guard
about him so we've got him we haven't
done that yet so much criticism mounting
now for the government not least because
of a what has been described as a lack
of PPE for frontline workers what would
labour be doing differently at this
point for me I'm actually going to
answer this question not as a Labour
politician I'm going to answer this as a
doctor on the frontline and I'm hearing
some colleagues all around the country
but quite frankly it is an abomination
that that the NHS
first off are simply not protected when
I did my shift on Saturday night I had
paramedics coming into some George's
saying that they'd only been given one
set of personal protective equipment for
an entire 12-hour shift if you think of
the numbers of houses that they go to
during that time we have already seen
that we have lost the nurse and four
doctors and there will be many more to
come people in the NHS need our care
service they go to work they oblige
they're out there working today to save
our mothers our fathers that bothers us
they absolutely have to be protected so
my plea as an NHS frontline worker would
be please please whatever was the
forward planning on this and let's make
sure that everybody that needs the PP he
gets it now as a politician and also as
a doctor where are we on testing well I
wrote to Matt Hancock just two days ago
and I said it's simply unacceptable that
there is not the testing available for
NHS staff but also that there is a fast
testing more widely available in the
same pmq that you kindly played a clip
on a moment ago I ask these very things
we knew about the first case in the UK
on the 31st of January we can see around
the world that in South Korea and in
Germany they stepped up testing
immediately and they were able to save
lives I wrote to my hand pop if I said
to him who are we engage in which
companies in the UK and around the world
I'll be engaging to get this right yes I
welcome the fact that assignment Stephen
said that NHS staff would be able to be
tested but there's some hospitals that
are only able to test to doctors or
nurses a day we simply do not have the
capacity
where was the forward planning on this
we knew this was coming and quite simply
it's an abomination that we are not able
to roll this out at lease or NHS and
care staff but it's a pandemic we need
to know the beast that we are fighting
at the moment and we can't do that if we
can't see it and without most testing we
don't know what we're working with but I
suppose a big confusion is about this
testing is you know you have the test
but the next thing you might pick it up
are you going to do it as a frontline
worker have to be tested every single
day
have symptoms and the better artists the
ladies at this point in time he has to
self isolate for a continued period if
you know if you can detect because we
already know that water
the villagers frontline staff are
currently off work that's making it much
okay you are on the front line at the
moment as we said doing your job for the
A&E answer the call when most needed if
you get the call on Saturday to be the
deputy leader will you also do that and
I've really enjoyed the campaign and
I've been so honored that they remembers
have allowed me to run in this race and
got me this far if I win on Saturday I
will be probably quite surprised that be
very happy and I would take on the role
with conviction but there is not a
single moment that I'm going to let down
my NHS staff on the front line working
to save lives
is a priority whether that be as a
politician or as a doctor okay okay and
what would you most the first thing if
you were a deputy leader what would be
the first thing that you would want and
you would pressurize the government to
do well I would actually continue what
I've been doing already which is pushing
for testing pushing for PPE but also the
question that I really want answered
which I've been very vocal about in this
last week is why are we only isolating
for seven days when the w-h-o
recommendation is 14 days and that is
what is being adopted by the rest of the
world we can see the numbers of deaths
arising on a daily basis we have only
recently put in socialist measures I
want full transparency almost is it that
we seem to know that the rest of the
world doesn't because it's not simply
okay to self isolate for seven days when
a whm have made it very clear you can
still be infectious look we're then
going to work to save lives in the NHS
we need the government and the public to
help us to help them